this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house greetings from podcast bill
the joint is brought to you by freeze
pipe listen it's getting cold out there
celebrate Fall by blowing a big icy
cloud in the woods with freeze pipe just
freeze it back it up and rip that
[__] listen the Hot Smoke faster
to the Frozen part cooling down the
smoke as you inhale it takes me back to
Colorado when I just scoop a little bit
of snow put in the bung and light that
[__] up I like my freeze pipe
whether it's the bubbler or the bung
those are my two favorites the bubble of
doubles is a pipe no no no no freeze pop
is non-toxic freezes faster than water
and stays Frozen longer freeze pipe
cools down the Smoke by hundreds of
degrees and now the freeze pipe is even
better they've updated their bong so you
have six independent freezing call for
even better airflow and much easier
cleaning experience I I love my freeze
pipe period I smoke out of that bong
every goddamn night and it is [__]
tremendous your Uncle Joe is taking care
of you so go to thefreeze pipe.com again
go to the freezepipe.com pressing code
Joey and save 10 off your first order
the holidays are coming get yourself a
new bong pipe or a bubblet today again
that's thefreeze pipe.com pressing code
Joey j-o-e-y to save 10 off your first
order the joint is also brought to you
by fitbot it's hard to find time to work
out fitbot tail is an exercise program
to your goals equipment and schedule and
it's easy to work out listen
I've never been into Exercise app but
this one is tremendous okay you open up
your fitbot app and you've got yourself
close to eight exercises two of them
being supersets they have a buzzer on
here a timer which helps you I mean this
is phenomenal tells you the body parts
you're working like today I'd be working
chess quads abs and my lower back it'll
come up every day with the exact workout
you need to do tell you about your days
off the videos make it easier to learn a
new routine it varies your routine for
you so you don't over train it's way
cheaper than a personal trainer and you
get a full year of personalized workouts
from fitbot for less than the cost of
one session with a personal trainer
fitbot is easy to use on both Apple and
Android devices and it's tremendous keep
your workout momentum going get
personalized workouts from football and
get tougher as you do I'm Gonna Get You
25 percent off again 25 off your
subscription or try out the app for free
when you sign up now at fitbot dot me
slash Joey again that's fitbot dot me
slash Joey that's 25 off your
prescription subscription only free at
fitbot.com dot me slash Joey again try
it for free at fitbot dot me slash Joey
and again it's Thursday [__]
the join is brought to you by DraftKings
you're like Joey what's going on tonight
tonight we got a tremendous game we got
Arizona laying two points in New Orleans
if you don't have a side they got plenty
of prop bets and on top of that Saturday
we're going to UFC 280 and get closer to
the octagon with DraftKings Sportsbook
an official sports betting partner the
UFC today right now new customers can
bet just five dollars on UFC 280 and get
200 and free that's if your fighter wins
everyone can boost their winnings with
DraftKings same game parlays I tell you
what I like Peter Yan this weekend
and I'm leaning toward my man Oliveira
come on the guy's been there two
thousand times if you bet 25 on the prop
bet you win 60 on an Oliveira who's
better than Uncle Joey and you can still
place a UFC same game parlay today
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now use promo code Joey and throw down
five on any UFC 280 bet and get 203 bets
when your fighter wins that's code Joey
this salad DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting part in the unfc
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details now go
download DraftKings and let's win some
[__] money let's get this party
started today I got a great guest we're
going to be talking about some great
stuff like that [__]
welcome to Uncle Joey's Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you sexy bastards Uncle
Joey here the 20th with Uncle Joey's
joint we have a great guest today a dear
friend of mine I love her her name is
Esther Lee she's a [__] pharmacist
extraordinaire we met through a couple
of moms in the neighborhood and we
become good friends as a matter of fact
she works at a great little uh
dispensary it's just medical right now
but she's here to talk about a product
she put on the market and I always
thought it was a good idea
I don't know anything about this [__]
but she's gonna educate you to the max I
know there's a lot of nice pretty girls
that watch this show a lot of women
watch this and I always try to have
something for you you know what I'm
saying but it's tough in my world but uh
here's asked to Lee to tell you about
her new product which I think is a
[__] tremendous idea and I'll get
into it later
it is uh break it down for me Esther
so the product is bouquet it is a
vaginal suppository
um and it's in healthier alternative to
the scented washes and the overly harsh
uh suppositories that's out there right
now that's commonly used
um
that's okay it's her first podcast you
know she wanted to come on and talk
about the product I thought it was a
great idea because first off I grew up
in the 70s and 80s there was no
education to let you know about anything
I mean now they're trying to put all
this sex education into schools and
whatnot so sure my daughter my nephew to
all learn things that I didn't know in a
general area but when you're a boy you
don't want to know about women's haha
you know you don't want to know nothing
about it they try to talk to you about
it but it's pretty interesting as you
get older you know you hook up with a
wife
and uh then you have a daughter like me
so you need to have some type of
knowledge and I remember when she was
telling me about it because she had a
couple different options to do it with
when we spoke about it we made what
caught my mind was that she spoke about
the ph and
all that stuff about the badge and even
if you talk about the men's junk right
I never knew what was going on and years
ago I was telling her when she got here
I was on the road
and I would I worked with a girl and one
night I didn't have any soap and she
came back with some of the vaginal scrub
and and at first it was like a joke I
put it on the loofah and I just wiped my
body with it and I scrubbed around the
man's hoo-ha with it and stuff but that
night when I got out of the shower I got
to be honest and I don't mean to creep
anybody out I had a different smell down
that it would smell fresh and the one
thing that stood out well how shiny my
nut sack was like it was [__] shiny
as [__] so I just took the summer Z
vaginal scrub and I used it for years I
didn't care what anybody said I just
used it for years because I was always
very self-conscious of what you smell
like down there I'm uncircumcised so you
know you got to keep that [__] up you
know so now when she spoke to me about
this for women you know listen you
always hear guys who try to be cute and
say that they bump to a jake that had
like a smelly hoo-ha or whatever
women usually don't even know what's
going on really you know they really
don't like this guy that was telling me
a story once this was like his fiancee
that had like a bad problem and she
didn't know and how do you tell a woman
that yeah something is refreshed the
same ways how does a woman tell a man
hey your nutsack stinks you know you
better put some Irish Spring in that
[__]
so I always think it's a great idea when
somebody I mean it's the future guys and
years ago this started with remember the
vaginal rejuvenation like in 1990s when
I got to L.A it was everywhere they were
even giving out vaginal rejuvenations at
7-Eleven it seemed like they were doing
everything this is what it became
you don't have to go to a place now to
take care of yourself and you know open
up your legs for some woman it's just
you don't need to do this anymore you
could just do this at home and this is
what I like about this that and it's
simple there's not a lot of stuff in
here not a lot of chemicals I was
looking at it you have like sodium
bicarbonate or something like that I'm
not good with pharmaceutical names
but it's simple and this is the future
and I know you have a you have you want
to grow with this which comes to mind
the the other side of your work right
now you're not at a traditional Pharmacy
anymore you're a 20th century woman now
so you're at a a dispensary you know so
you get to meet
CBD THC with this product yeah so that's
the future tell me about it yeah thank
you so much for just sharing that in
your humor it's making me a little less
nervous but um yeah so it's not sodium
bicarb just for the listeners it is
lactose three ingredients it's lactose
and um it's just three ingredients
lactose magnesium stearate and silicon
dioxide and that's just to hold it
together and what I love about this is
that it is
it's so I think the biggest
misconception right now is that like you
mentioned Summer's Eve and that's a
product that's definitely definitely
going to help women or anyone that uses
it smell better but it's not necessarily
going to help the root cause and it
actually makes us more susceptible to pH
imbalances and infections so that's
because
good bacteria is a huge topic right now
I'm sure everybody's heard about it with
your GI tracts your digestive tract yeah
so good bacteria is in our vaginal Flora
just like it's in our digestive tract
and it plays a really helpful role in
keeping us clean it's a very
self-cleaning organ
so these soaps can actually Over clean
and it'll kind of wipe out too much of
our good bacteria and it kind of
disrupts that really important and
delicate balance
um the cause of odor which
so it's it's crazy because it's
something so common up to 80 of women
experience vaginal odor at least two to
three times every two to three weeks
and and I say that because
I just want women to feel seen and I
don't want women to feel like they have
this thing that they need to clean or I
don't want them to feel like they're
dirty um because that's I feel like the
word feminine hygiene can sometimes
imply that it's a hygienic issue it's
like you're not cleaning yourself and
it's really a balance issue and what
that is I can get a little scientific
um but our Flora is lined with our
natural bacteria which is lactobacillus
it's it's a probiotic I think many
viewers will know what it is
and it also has a bacteria called
gardnerella and that also it just
naturally exists in our vaginal Flora
um but when that balance is disrupted
when they are kind of there and there's
enough lactobacillus kind of balancing
each other out that's what we would want
optimally but sometimes we are prone to
imbalances there's two there's an
overgrowth of a disruptive fact of the
gardnerella which can produce these side
effects like irritation and odor so when
we know that it's kind of easier to have
for me at least when I know the root
cause of something or when I have an
understanding it just helps like I know
that there's nothing wrong with me it's
just something this is why this is
happening to me and that's kind of the
information that I'd love to put out
there for women and this product what it
does is it supports the good bacteria it
supports the growth of the good bacteria
so the concept and the angle is very
different it's not not about trying to
like oh you have to clean yourself you
have to get rid of this odor causing
kind of condition you have going on it's
more but no let's support the good
things that we already have the body is
very sufficient it's very the body is
amazing it's very capable of healing
itself but we can always do things here
and there to help and that's what
bouquet is about it's funny I said odor
and I I shouldn't have said older that's
the person that came to my mind
but sometimes you don't even have to
have odor it's just something it's not
right down there you know with anybody
it could be a male let's not just pick
on women here male [__] stink too you
know and I have a gay friend who tells
me a bunch of crazy stories about guys
and I'm like that's why I hate guys
because we just felt the animals that's
how this whole thing started because I
I've always taken three showers a day
like since I was a little boy something
my mom put into me or whatever like I
always took three showers a day and
sometimes that's not even enough it
could be something you're reading it
could be so many things that affect your
area down there so when I said older it
was just one of the things sometimes you
don't even have to have order to have an
imbalance you know it'll maybe come out
with discharge it doesn't have to be an
odor or something it could just be a
funny thing happened to me when I was
younger when I was about 20
I dated a girl was very promiscuous and
I was you know I'm a Catholic guy I
don't like promiscuous girls but she was
a lot of fun to hang out with
so I started dating it and after we
broke up like months later I had a weird
odor I don't know if again I went to the
doctor I didn't know what it was
and he said something to that effect to
me that maybe she had had some type of
bacteria you know I wasn't going to call
her and tell her you know some of my
business hopefully by then she figured
it out it didn't it wasn't like getting
covered or getting AIDS or something
like that so I just felt embarrassed
having to call somebody
saying that to them but it wasn't an
older thing on them
it became an older thing on me later on
with the bacteria so
I've always and then I went to a buddy
of mine called VD
and I went to the clinic with him one
time because he was embarrassed
and once I went to that clinic I saw a
couple weird things in there and that's
why I didn't really like promiscuous
women and stuff when I was a kid I was
always like well be careful I went to
the VD clinic and I saw some weird [__]
in there so it was very weird in there
that day when you're 16 it scared the
hell out of me even more so I've always
been into that but
by you doing this product I think you're
going to open the door to so many things
I mean we had discussed like maybe
putting CBD in there how would that
change in a little bit well our brand
Mission when we were coming up with just
the branding was that the vagina
deserves to be celebrated for all the
work it's done and all the work it's
going to do and I thought that was
really uplifting and powerful and I
could see something like CBD just being
right in line with that and
um not just looking at something that we
need to fix but but thinking of ways we
can enjoy vaginal care making it
something like my hope is to make
vaginal care like skin care just as
normal and just as enjoyable that women
can use something to to As a treat
and something that they can add to like
their self-care routine when they have
their at-home like spa days and I think
something like CBD is right in line with
that because it's very complementary and
it doesn't make women feel like they
have this problem or this smell or like
a dysfunctional vagina
[Laughter]
I wanted to run it by you because what I
thought was amazing about this product
was that there are a lot of people in
the sex industry right now and you know
with all the different diseases that
they say syphilis is making a comeback
and I mean this isn't going to help you
with any of this stuff
but I'm just saying that you got to keep
yourself clean with what's going on in
the world right now you have the monkey
pox all this stuff
is coming up so I forgot what I was
gonna say I got so stuck up with the
uh
but uh
I think even like yeah when you after
you give birth you might have some
issues down there this I don't want to
keep going back to the Yoda because it
makes me feel shitty for saying it but
there's just so many things that you
know when a woman goes to yoga like
there's just so it works out I've heard
so many different stories I read some
about a year ago
that you shouldn't uh
again we're going back to sex that women
have to be very careful when getting
fingered because of the germs on hands
like I read this during covet like
people were concerned about all this
[__]
so there's so many things that could
just you know and I don't know much
about the vagina I I don't know the
mechanics of it I know how to look at
them and then giggle that's it that's
all I know right because yeah but the
guy looks at when we just smile you know
like we leave I'm like giggle like
[__] idiots
but I I really appreciate your
sensitivity around the topic yeah no and
yeah and that's why I was so excited to
be here today because it's I know you
you talk about a lot of things for men
and it's true older is and and I love
that you kind of were sensitive around
that topic as well
um and just one of how common one of the
most common
um kind of vaginal issues that women
experience is vaginosis and it's pretty
much when there's an imbalance when
there's a decrease of your good bacteria
and you have symptoms like irritation
and odor and discharge but so this
affects up to one in three women so 30
of women are
are diagnosed with this so there's
probably more that aren't diagnosed and
of those women I think they were saying
about 50 are asymptomatic so we don't
even have symptoms and we kind of are
have these imbalances and not to scare
people some people are you know not as
sensitive to it but it's just nice to
know that these things are very common
and this is what's happening and it's
not always going to show up as odor for
everyone but it's just good to know that
especially for women like when we are
prone to imbalances and a lot of those
situations like you I think you
mentioned something with yoga so yeah a
lot of it is just everyday lifestyle
things it's not because you're
promiscuous or because you're you know
it's not an STD it's not because of
anything you should feel ashamed about
it's a lot of it is just everyday things
like having your period or even stress
for women it shows up as an imbalance in
their flora and I think and I just love
that you already the way you talk about
it it is I don't know if you're just
being so nice because I'm here but it's
like it's uh yeah like I don't think a
lot of men view it that way and it's so
uh issue of imbalances and sensitivity
just like something like acne or like
skin sensitivity some of us can stay out
in the sun all day or some of us don't
have barely have to wash their face and
they have Perfect Skin me if I don't
like if I don't do my treatments and
stuff I'm gonna start breaking out in
two days so I think women have to know
that it's just everybody is very
different and we just show like stress
in different ways as well yeah so and
and I say I go over this a little bit in
on the website on like the situations
where we are
um prone to imbalances and some of them
is what you had mentioned sexual
activity increases our risk also just
menstruation semen so just and also like
hormonal imbalance not imbalances but
hormonal changes that women go through
every month and that can increase change
our pH
that's what it's crazy how I go on
Twitter and the Instagrams and whatever
and there's a group of girl on Twitter
that I met him at the comedy store and
she's very cool funny crazy
and she goes out every weekend to a
different city like Miami Houston Dallas
and they go to a hotel and they have
outdoor orgies and it's like one chick
with four guys and every Monday they put
them up on Twitter I get banned from
Twitter if I put a picture of [__]
weed up there but this chick is having
threesomes you know the whole thing and
every Monday I look at what they've gone
through in the back of my mind I'm like
[__] Esther can help these chicks
right now these chicks put their monkeys
through War over the weekend with and
nobody's wearing a condom
you know like in all these things when I
look nobody has a condom on I hope
they're getting tested for AIDS and
anything else but even without the com
without the condom and whatever God
knows what you're putting in your body
and this goes for both of us this goes
for men and for [__] women you know I
mean what if a woman has a bacteria
issue and a guy goes down on her you
know
yeah or bad teeth he has a [__]
cavity and he goes down and up with a
cavity or a [__] abscess in his mouth
or some [__] I mean these are the things
that happen guys this this happens it's
funny but this is what happens
like does a lot of sex like that like I
mean and she's having sex with [__]
stallions right like they're not little
dick dude she's having sex with Giants
I mean I don't even know if your product
can help I mean it's like a double you
know but I like to do a survey with them
and they're gonna be here next week oh
that's awesome yeah I don't think the
all the ladies are coming but she hit me
up and she's like I'm being exotic if
you want to swing and say hello they're
very sweet women they just they do what
they do this is what they do for fun I'm
not gonna you know I smoke pot and eat
mushrooms they like to go out and get
laid in the pool everybody has different
things so I'm not going to judge them
but in the back of my mind I always it's
like I took a friend of mine a dear
friend of mine or a rock concert
it was one of Dean Delray's parties
and I introduced to like Rudy sarso or
something and I go Felicia is really
really Felicia when he walked away Rudy
Felicia looks at me she goes if anybody
needs conditioner it's him and I'm like
out of all the [__] things that you
could say about somebody you know
you're talking about it this guy can
have conditioner so when I look at those
girls doing all those things all weekend
which again I have nothing against them
I think about wow they should really be
taking care of themselves because as a
man if I was there at that RG I know
when I come home I do like a mask
whatever I could do down there to sleep
better you know a mask a cucumber on the
pole whatever I can you know to sleep
better you know how they put cucumbers
on their eyes I was just thinking what
happens if you put a cucumber on a pee
hole but you know all that stuff worries
me like I'm a [__] prude a lot of
part my wife will tell you like a lot of
my [__] is kind of prudish I mean I like
it you know I like sex and stuff but
that's what's always held me back from
that sex was going to that VD Clinic
when I was 16 and seeing people walking
all [__] up
can something like this I mean with the
CBD and everything well you were saying
like if you do this you can't have sex
for a few days no so this is one of the
things I love about
um this product as well it's so it's
just pretty much we can think about it
like a vitamin for your vaginal Flora so
it's really not irritating and it's not
something that you have to give it time
to kind of wear off or clean out you can
use it I mean there is going to be a
residue because it is a tablet that's
gonna like melt inside but other than
that you there really is no waiting
period for some so for those women that
do kind of put them their vaginas
through a lot this would be something
that's great for them that they can use
in between just to kind of replenish
their flora and I I kind of want to be
careful
um as I go on this journey with this
product too not to instill any anxiety
with people because I just find that
these days even with myself because
there's so much information on social
media like I you start to think you have
everything like you have to like even
like I know it's really good practice to
pee after you have sex but like even
these like things it helps to know it
but sometimes you get really anxious
like oh my God what if I didn't and I'm
gonna have an infection so I just want
to remind people that and I don't want
women to feel like oh you're so prone to
having an infection like you're you have
to do this no like your vagina is very
capable of cleaning itself it's almost
you really don't need to use a lot of
these scented washes and like I
mentioned before they act the scented
washes can make the imbalances worse if
anything
um but I just want women to
to know that if you are experiencing
imitate irritation or order this is
something that can support your Flora
from the inside it's like a targeted
relief for them that they can use and
honestly just I know I said this before
too but I really just hope that women
feel seen and heard
because I think the feminine hygiene
industry now just I don't think they've
done a good job at that and just
especially because a lot of these
products just the fact that it doesn't
really help the root cause
of the symptoms that we're trying to get
relief from what made you come up with
this product
um you were thinking one day and said
you know what
um women need to take care
long story
um so I around 2000
18. I was experiencing I was like
feeling really anxious about
um just my career as a pharmacist I was
working in retail
and I think I've learned a lot about my
personality now but I think it's just
this like I felt really stuck and I have
a fear of that and when I feel stuck is
when I get anxious
um so I was seeing it my I was going
over this with my therapist and
uh we were going through all these
different like she was so helpful we
went through all these like personality
tests to try to because I had done
Pharmacy for so long that I didn't know
what else I could do
and she was just trying to help me
um kind of find out what my strengths
are and where I could explore
and at that time what I wanted to do was
something for women in like the bra
industry because I had gone through a
lot
um as like Christina knows that I'd gone
through a lot with I had gone through
like multiple rounds of like breast
augmentation and just taking them out
and I was in a really like like a
vulnerable space because while I was
healing I wasn't allowed to wear wired
bras I had to wear these bralettes and I
just couldn't find anything that was
appropriate so I had to make these like
makeshift bras at home
um and I have this like funny story
because I've
um I was bowling with my my church
community and I was I had to like put
these paddings in and when I was
bullying it like came out and luckily no
one saw but I was just going through
this like time where I was getting kind
of frustrated
and I just couldn't find anything out
there so that's my therapist had
encouraged me she was like I think you
have something and I think you have like
a heart for it so I think this is
something you really care about and I
kind of she and then we went through
like with the personality test how I
like to problem solve so
she just really encouraged me and pushed
me to start she's like it all just you
just have to start like whether it's
researching three four hours a day
whatever that looks like she was like
that's where I've seen women do it and
they just have to know that they can and
there has to be a beginning
um so that's what I was doing and then
while I was doing I was exploring that
um
realm of women and like I wanted to do
something that was empowering for women
with the bras but then I started seeing
um
this kind of
like lack in the vaginal hygiene
industry and a lot of my friends were
coming to me with like they needed
antibiotics because I was at a pharmacy
and I was at that time I attended a
actually a longevity conference
um
and at that conference the whole
conference was about probiotics and good
bacteria and just how important it is
for us to take it and how depleted we
are nowadays and from there I started
just one and then I started reading
about how we need to go bacteria in the
vagina and I just started wondering like
how the oral probiotics will help us
vaginally like how does it end up there
and it kind of just piqued my curiosity
and when I was at the pharmacy I was
also doing I was compounding vaginal
suppositories for a hormone called
progesterone so it all just like kind of
came together and I started researching
trying to see what else is out there
yeah it took a lot of time this was like
two years of me just kind of floating
around and looking at what's out there
and then I did find a very similar
product like this available but I just
hated the
the messaging behind it and I just felt
like and I used the products and they
and it did help me and that's where I
kind of wanted to tweak it and make it
something
that was had a different messaging than
like
I felt that the products that were out
there I just I don't want to name any
names but yeah I just felt like it was
something that I had to use and kind of
hide like it was kind of embarrassing to
have like it's almost like having a
modium like I don't want people to know
I have diarrhea so yeah I was like you
know why doesn't we women don't have
anything like this for them like
something that they could be proud to
use and just just feel like they're
taking care of themselves and even
display and just be like hey yeah this
is something that I use and I feel sexy
or using it and that's kind of where my
mind was at and I think in the beginning
I didn't I think the hardest
kind of step for me was just going for
it
um yeah because I'm a very idea person
like I'll have all these ideas but not
much so does everybody yeah so but
that's how yeah it started pulling the
trig is always tough what an idea and
you're embarrassed you don't know for
the work you know failure is always
looming so
it's courageous you did a great job with
it now let me ask you this how would you
in the future
when you add CBD to this product how
would that
would that really take it to a different
level yeah I think so I think CBD right
now and even I would love to see both
like CBD and THC we have so many forms
of that at the dispensary we have
topical THC and CBD and you know
patients do really well with it and I
think it can definitely help with women
and just with extensive heightening
sensitivity and also with women that may
have inflammation where it's or
irritation it could help with that too I
mean of course we would have to kind of
test it out and see I think that's
what's so like exciting about CBD right
now is that there's so much to learn
um but I absolutely think that there is
a place for it and it's definitely going
to I think it's something that women
will love
it's crazy you know when I got hit up by
manscape I don't know five years ago
I was like this is the [__] perfect
product like this is you know I've
always been trimming around down there
you know but once manscape put it out I
I thought it was a great product it was
a great product for me to push
in a comical way because I could get
guys to use it over the years like I had
a lot of comic friends
a lot of female friends that you know
spoke freely in front of me and they
would talk about guys they were dating
or situations they would have and I
would pick up little cuesome and go okay
I gotta double check on that you know
what I'm saying I better make sure I got
that [__]
and that's why when manscape approached
me I loved the idea I love that they
have a tightener for I don't know yeah
they have a refresher and they have like
a little
you could put a little thing in your
wallet and if you're getting ready to go
to war you could do like a last wipe and
it's got like VH and all that stuff so
the person you're with doesn't [__]
get insulted so I always like that stuff
I I you know I always think listen
what's this isn't there a [__] uh
whatever cleanliness is Next to
Godliness so I always was extra like and
then I got heavy so I'm like man when
you get heavy you smell like cheese so I
I would take even I would take even more
showers than I would like shove in
between like creases and stuff and I've
always been very I don't like being
dirty like I don't know especially your
private part so when you came up with
this I think with with manscape and this
I could cover everybody's world you know
like a little bit I mean women trimmed
themselves and they go for Brazilian
bulge or whatever the [__] they do
but uh what is that what is that called
Brazilian blowout or something I think
it's a Brazilian wax Brazilian wax
that's what it is and that that takes
all the hair out the blow out is when I
blow with a blow dryer it looks like
[__] Michael Jackson I've never heard
about that yeah it doesn't work yeah
you gotta add some humor to this because
uh
it is a very great product I'm happy
you [__] put it together you know I'm
happy I've known you since when you were
struggling to put the pieces together we
went up to dispensary and I'm happy you
put it out now how can they find this
um right now our website you can go to
our website it's with bouquet.com with
yeah bokeh.com how do you spell bouquet
b-o-p-o-q-u-e-t okay the regular and
then you can check us out on Instagram
it's the same handles with bouquet on
Instagram
this is going places man I have a funny
feeling about this now you were saying
when you came in that you wanted to
cover the dispensary stuff that you're
doing also yeah yeah because this
matches in the middle somewhere this
meets in the middle yeah I know I just
you know I I always have an appreciation
for
for just the timing and when I met you
because I
that was when I was interviewing right
for the dispensary and I was a little I
wasn't sure you know if this was
something that I would be good at and I
remember Christina who is our mutual
friend she was so encouraging and she
was just so kind enough to introduce us
and it was after I met you I truly got
so excited and I think that's what
helped me to just like nail the
interview because that excitement just
it showed through and it was like
apparently talking about CBD and the
different uses of CBD yeah yeah I
thought like CBD by itself has a great
uh result but if you wanted to really
kick up a little bit a little THC that's
why they have like that one-to-one
balance the one I have in the draw so we
were talking about that stuff and I I
really believed in CBD I think because
I'm a bigger dude it hasn't like it's
just shame some people's lives I work
with CBD lion and they have great CBD
like
but the tinctures and stuff helped me
with my anxiety and they helped me sleep
a little better at night like whenever I
take my tincture my REM sleep I'll hit
REM sleep at least a little better you
know for my shoulder I put the cream on
and that's fantastic for my knees and
stuff it gives you great relief I just
don't want people to think that if they
have a bum knee and they buy CBD it's
going to fix it like that's that's what
scares me about all that stuff it's like
when I have sleep apnea and nothing
bothers me more is when I see sleep
apnea products like not sleep apnea
products but products that are a
shortcuts that are not going to help you
they're not going to help you it's just
you just drop 50 bucks on something just
go get the [__] sleep apnea machine
you know I hate all those in the medium
products that give somebody hope yeah
and they're like [__] I still got the
sleep apnea machine yeah so
it's over promising yes you know and
this keeps it simple like I don't want
people to ever think that well I'm gonna
have sex with 20 guys put one of these
things in and I'm Healed you know it's
going to take time to balance and
rejuvenate and whatever the [__] up it's
the same thing for a man you know if he
has if he lives like a [__] animal
and then comes home on Monday and he's
got a bump down there what happened why
are you with 20 women you know that's
not going to help you the thing around
it'll help you but at least thistle make
everything feel a lot better yeah yeah
no and that just thank you for bringing
that up because another
um important note is that there is a
rule for gynecologists and antibiotics I
think sometimes like and that's what I
would want people to know too like if
you have an infection or if you have
recurring symptoms definitely get it
checked out but if you take antibiotics
one of the side effects is that you can
your Flora might need some replenishing
like it could wipe out all the good
bacteria too so that's a great time to
add something like bouquet and use it in
like after your antibiotic treatment to
help you restore your good bacteria when
women are on antibiotics what happens
they can't do something that's something
I heard when I was
younger like a friend of mine was an
antibiotic she couldn't do anything for
a couple weeks I figured it's a totally
different for women when you take
antibiotics or something oh you gotta
eat yogurt oh yes the yoga definitely
yoga for the good bacteria yeah yeah
it's crazy because I'm taking it uh
whatever the [__] amoxicillin now right
and I was like the other day I was like
man I've been going to the bathroom
regularly my stomach is not bothering me
I started taking this product called
armor
it's what they give you it's what's in a
mother's milk
when she first feeds you colostrum okay
and I guess in some countries they use
colostrum as a like a supplement or it's
a supplement but it's also a you can't
use it for some stuff because it flags
on your pee test no it's considered a
enhancer like that so I have the other
stuff it's a company called amra
and it's so weird to have over 200
nutrients in this thing where did you
get it
friend of mine from California a woman
trainer that is legit called me like
I've known her since college and we
reconnected in Los Angeles 10 years ago
and when I met her she was just one of
those girls that I used to go this chick
has the worst [__] job in the world
she would change guys socks in the
football field and put tape their ankles
and all that [__] she was one of those
girls but she was also a strength and
conditioning coach
and I guess at the extent to Colorado
she told me she stayed in Boulder for a
while and trained some people and she
went out to LA and she started training
like you know high-end Executives and
stuff like that
she calls me when she thinks something's
going to help me she wanted to check in
and she goes you can look you should
look into this arm armor
it's a hundred and nine dollars
for maybe a three month supply it's like
just a thing and you only put when I
tell you you put two capsules you're
supposed to start with one capsule
and then the more you you know as you
build in your system put another one in
beside this cold and this migraine
headache it's been helping I feel
[__] great like I feel great
and I was reading up on it before I when
I started taking the antibiotics I got
to get some of those two ounce Prebiotic
things and I'm like why this thing says
it's going to be great and I got to be
honest it's great it's worked perfectly
I'm down to one more
antibiotics then I'm done and uh let's
see where the [__] the stakes is but
I've been starting to use more
probiotics and I started last year we
had a company that sponsored this for a
while magnesium company and they were
really good this company we just didn't
do well with them so they went away
but I started using their products and I
could notice just in the probiotics yeah
how different I was feeling yeah you
know [__] that you eat maybe doesn't
agree with you
so now I'm a Believer in them so when
this armor came up and they had it then
I go yeah just give it to me and I tell
you I feel a lot better like I I feel a
little thinner
it lays down the inflammation it takes
off a lot of inflammation and it's
basically whatever the colostrum I've
never heard of that but I'm very
interested yeah it's the it's whatever
is in your breast milk when you first
feed your child like once they take them
out of you yeah and they bring them back
and they take to the breast boom that's
the first dose of milk and it has like a
lot of antibodies in it it's great for
the colds and stuff you just got to read
up I'm no I'm no [__] doctor but
probiotics had made me feel a lot better
last year and I've been using them now
consistently so that makes [__] sense
I didn't know they had to use them in
conjunction with something else but it
all makes sense a little Esther yeah
yeah I definitely notice a difference
too and I use them like sometimes I have
gone like I go on and off and every time
I I do and don't I definitely notice the
difference especially in my skin which I
think is really interesting there has to
be some really share with your like got
nothing will help my skin
I've had shitty skin since I was like
five I got one summer in Miami I caught
like sunburns on my arm and it went all
the way down like it was like third
degree burns and then I played like I
don't know basketball when I was seven I
went to take a shower at the place and I
came back like the worst foot fungus
like I had blisters and pimples so I
wasn't allowed to take showers when the
[__] gym no more I couldn't take a
shower with boys I couldn't do it I
didn't have a regular I don't want to
take a shower with boys anymore yeah
this ain't no [__] whatever they say
no disco but I had all those problems
coming up and then as I got older they
went away Tuesday I'm going to longevity
and it's a whole day of needles and
and I'm excited about this because I'm
going to turn 60 and the medical I don't
know what's going on with medic doctors
and what's going on in the world now
every time you call your doctor it's a
four a four week
for an appointment and this is the
second time I've called that I'm waiting
on 72 hours for a call back yeah so
somewhere along the line the medical
profession is just buckled somewhere
I want to make sure that everything is
all right with me so I'm going to go in
there give them blood I'm gonna do the
whole thing I think you you check in at
eight and you don't leave there till 4
30. oh wow they feed you two times it's
a lot of money I saved some money away
in My Little Acorn account
worth it I think that's awesome I think
that's a great investment listen man you
invest in yourself I mean it's not like
I'm a kid anymore you know I have a
daughter I want to be here yeah for a
few more years I want to be here for my
wife these are our golden years so I'm
gonna go down there as much as I don't
like [__] needles none of them white
paying a lot of money from my doctor
stuff you just gotta go for it and go in
there and it's Men's Health this is what
you know this is what we're doing right
now we're trying to yeah you know I had
a rough life I did drugs and [__] I've
been clean for 15 years so I don't drink
I don't do anything anymore not because
I'm in the program I just don't drink
but I just felt it was time this is
thorough I haven't had a prostate exam
in four years since with the pandemic
and everything yeah I haven't had chest
X-rays I mean nothing these doctors have
taken more and more away from the
physical like when I went to a physical
in LA and that dude was busy as hell but
he would do chest x-rays a prostate exam
you know he would talk to me about
different stuff and look at my throat
and look at my ears the last physical I
went to Esther
was so [__] bad
I was like what the [__] no chest x-ray
no prostate exam
she took my weight my blood pressure and
asked me a bunch of questions and she's
like you're free to go and then they
drew blood yeah and they read my chart
but that that's not it's very in and now
it's just an exchange very in and out so
you know like last week I had to
actually go to urgent care I couldn't
even see my doctor I had migraine
headaches I can't [__] breathe and
she's like I don't know what to tell you
you know what the [__] to tell me I mean
so I don't know what's going on with the
medical system in this country right now
ever since covered somewhere along the
line it's uh it's kind of broken I hate
to say that word but yeah this is the
fee we got to start taking care of
ourselves a little more and go outside
the box I don't care if you go on
expressvpn
I don't care if you go on there and look
at the internet the dark web
for stuff like this that could help you
I'm not saying this is going to be on
the dark web what I'm saying is that
there's a lot of products that are great
for you out there people don't have
access to them they're small companies
like yourself you don't have a big
budget to go on NBC no and you know
advertise on the [__] uh World Series
and [__] like that so
we do what the [__] we do but I'm happy
you put this together Esther
I want you to come back every time you
add something to this yeah yeah I would
love to
um and this is like the baby steps right
now yeah this is like the so fresh
um for me like beginning this journey so
it's so I'm just so grateful to be here
I'm grateful that you're here remember
ask the Little Steps yeah become big
steps it's so weird how we have a job
but in that job we always wanna we have
a dream and you look at your job
you go you know what it's too late I
have kids I have a husband
I don't really have time to do what my
dream is but
you know man you did it you know some
people don't have the time you made it
work for you and I think this is the
beginning of a lot of good things for
you Esther I think from this you never
know you might open this up [__] uh
summer Zee reaches out to you 10 million
to shut the [__] up and get out of the
market go sell weed they'll tell you now
you got 10 million dollars and you're
living like a doctor so nothing Little
Steps become big steps and I think that
this little step was big for you now
you're ready to do and then you call me
up and go hey man I cut my hours at the
pharmacy by 10 hours then 10 hours then
10 hours and pretty much you're doing
this full-time yeah you know so
it's a journey it's just it's the
beginning but just that you did it and
uh that's all that counts man I'm really
happy that you did it
and this is how we do it here in the
church on the joint [__] church I
gotta stop eating those [__]
mushrooms a few people want to know I
did not get the role I auditioned for in
the Nero movie it went through a name
who gives a [__] I was there baby boy
they put my picture on the wall that's
all that [__] matters I got to meet
Barry I got to read with Robert again
that was great and this is part of the
deal guys you keep going to them and
eventually something sticks on the
[__] wall listen I'm owing four on my
last four auditions that's not me at all
I usually if you sent me out I could pop
one thing so that means when you get a
bunch of those that you just closer to a
[__] yes I love Noah sometimes
because the more nodes you get
you you're going to get a Yes somewhere
[__] along the line and that's it man
so that's where I stand on a beautiful
[__] Thursday morning short and sweet
no drama as the Lee came on talk to you
about bouquet
I can't see without my glasses it's just
a [__] bouquet there you go and it
smells good in here can I smell it
it's not dead it doesn't happen
okay but there's no fragrance
so did you just put this that's it yup
you inserted about it inch or two to
where it's comfortable let it warm up to
your body temperature let it dissolve
and I got an idea for your podcast
the podcast you're going to start for
this stuff is going to call Esther Lee's
vagina party I love it you gotta put a
little cake with those [__] lights in
it that explodes like on your birthday
at Osteria with the things and that's
going to be the name I think that's a
great name you're empowering woman
and I think this is needed right now in
the podcast world so Esther Lee's new
podcast coming soon is Esther Lee
putting it out there vaginal party Jack
you know what I'm saying [__] kazoos
whatever
yeah you can you can coach me on how to
do that yeah you could do it yourself
you just did it just come on every week
you just come on every weekend and give
information it doesn't have to be funny
yeah it just has to be you and correct
information so they don't you don't end
up on Spotify giving out bad info and
[__] and I think it's a great idea yes I
think this is ready you're ready you
have great guests you have our [__]
matriarch yes Christine Myrtle over
there [__] uh Miss swam assist
herself
and I think it's a great idea Esther
because you just told me about what you
wanted to do and I'm like yeah this is
Esther's vagina part once a month
[__] on YouTube just draw a bunch of
your friends to come over you drink some
wine you insert a bunch of these words
a sheet mask some cucumbers on your eyes
yeah I feel it I'm feeling great I'm not
feeling anything I've put two in there
so far
well I'm happy you came on and took the
time thank you again tell these Savages
where you can get this for your
girlfriend your wives
anybody your grandma you know Grandma
walks a little slow maybe this will put
a little pep in the [__] step you
know what I'm saying Grandma hasn't seen
no light since the Nixon Administration
so oh yeah so please come check us out
our Instagram is with bouquet and our uh
website is with bouquet.com
and that's it and that's that
[__] Uncle Joey loves you today
is short and sweet we'll be back Monday
morning Tip Top Magoo for Halloween week
stay black I love you and now for a
[__] word for my sponsors Jack
all right you bad [__] I want
to thank Esther Lee and I probably
bouquet and I want to thank you guys for
the support it was short and sweet today
no [__] drama okay the joint is
brought to you by fitbot listen it's
hard to find time to work out football
tail is an exercise program to your
goals equipment and schedule it's the
easiest way to work out this app is
tremendous I don't know if you've ever
used an exercise app before I haven't
but this app has blown me away
they have videos to make it easy to
learn a new routine so if you don't know
the proper movement boom you click on
that button they'll tell you it varies
your routine so you will never over
train it's way cheaper than a personal
trainer you get a full year of workouts
for less than one training session
fitbot is easy to use on Apple and
Android devices keep your workout
momentum going get healthy for the new
year start today with fitbot get
personalized workouts from football God
that get tougher as you get tougher I'm
going to get hit you with a 25 off your
subscription when you try out the app
for free joy what are you talking about
you can try it for free when you sign up
now at fitbot dot me slash Joey again
fitbod dot me slash Joey that's 25 off
your subscription or try it for free at
fitbot dot me slash Joey the joint is
also brought to you by freeze pipe
listen you know I like smoking reef and
I like to do it nicely comfortably why
not out of a [__] the freeze pipe you
freeze it you pack it up and you smoke
that [__] till your eyeball pops
out the hot smoke passes through the
Frozen part cooling down the smoke as
you inhale I love freeze pipe it takes
me back to my days in Colorado where I
just go out in the backyard and put it
up but this is completely different
freeze pipe is non-toxic and it freezes
faster than water and stays Frozen
longer freeze pipe cool down the Smoke
by hundreds of degrees now freeze pipe
is even better 2023 they've updated
their bong so you have six independent
freezing calls for even better airflow
and a much easier cleaning experience so
listen Uncle Joe is always taking K
today it's with the freeze pipe.com
pressing code Joey to save 10 on your
first order the holidays are coming take
care of yourself get yourself a new bong
pipe or bubble or get all [__] three
of them that's thefreeze pipe.com
pressing code Joey I'm Gonna Save You
ten percent and listen the weekend is
upon us the holidays are upon us and you
still haven't downloaded the DraftKings
Sportsbook app what the [__] are we
talking about here this weekend you got
UFC 280 you're going to get close to the
Octagon you're going to feel the [__]
Sweat Right Now new customers can bet
finals on any UFC 280
fight and get 200 and free bets when
your fighter wins everyone can boost
their earnings with draft game
DraftKings same game Paul is what's that
Joey you pick two things and you bet
them you want to boost your winnings the
more lays you add the more money you win
so place a UFC same game parlay today
you're allowed one per day download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app now use promo
code Joey
throw down five dollars in the UFC 280
and get 203 bets if your fighter wins
that's called Joey j-o-e-y this Saturday
in DraftKings but the party starts
tonight you got Arizona minus two
against New Orleans in the Prime game of
the week that's code Joey download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app and let's get
this party started that was they also
have a fantasy app that'll make your
[__] pubic hairs jump out of your
[__] [__] minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details now do me a favor
download the DraftKings app and go win
some [__] money I want to thank
DraftKings I want to thank fitbud and I
want to thank the freeze pipe for
another great week of podcast I also
want to thank my girl Esther Lee for
coming in and talking to us about a new
product you gotta change it up from time
to time guys why not have a [__]
genius come on the show I love you guys
have a great weekend stay black and I'll
see you guys Monday morning Tip Top
Magoo
foreign
[Music]